oh my god you're making me nervous
you're actually making me nervous do you
not know no i do you're making me
nervous
hi everybody i'm megan rupino and this
is my fiancee
i'm sue bird and this is the gq couples
quiz
which i'm pretty sure we're gonna fail
miserably so
here we go let's dive right in okay to
kick us off
what's my hidden talent i think your
hidden talent
is interpretive dance is it interpretive
the right way
yeah you could be see his back okay yeah
the xx interpretive dances yeah
close to my heart what's my favorite
accessory just one
maybe your watch i think you're right
which watch the rolex yeah
you're right she got this for me post
world cup
splurge what is my dream travel
destination or vacation
tahiti yes in the huts
you win what are my parents first names
um denise oh my god you're making me
nervous
you're actually making me nervous no i
do you're making me nervous
all i can think of right now is jack's
restaurant that was grandpa's name jack
i know
i know same letter i know
yes wow just got nervous oh you did you
got a little red
i know i'm sorry jim i do know your name
what am i most scared
of i think you have this like irrational
fear that people are going to think
you're like a fraud
that is true you went deep on that yeah
it's like some of the work you do
can be kind of like in sensitive areas
and you feel like
oh i don't want people questioning my
intentions because you have obviously
benefited at times yeah i also don't
want to be buried alive
so that definitely
what is my biggest pet peeve you really
hate when i leave the sink faucet thing
on the other setting
yeah and you hate my hair in the
bathroom i don't love it the hair less
so because it's like it falls out and
you have
beautiful curly thick hair good recovery
thank you gosh i don't even know if i
know when this is when is
megan repino day in reading california
i think you're july 5th no i think it's
just like when you were
won the world cup yes i think it's in
september at some point
september 10th what's my favorite music
song artist to listen to before a game
oh nipsy hustle so good
when was our first date like the day
if i had to guess i would say somewhere
in like the september 20s
yeah and we went to betty we did yeah
you're right i don't know
exactly i know except your freaking
dad's name that's going to haunt me for
the rest of my life jim's going to
because i know it
obviously i know it i got very nervous
and all i could think of was jack
what's my favorite movie or tv show of
all time
you don't thrive in these categories of
all time
i don't even think you know the answer
do you megan what is your favorite movie
it's either shawshank okay or have you
seen it
i have i've actually seen it a lot okay
or uh
ace ventura oh right even all right
and what oh a tv show yeah i don't think
you have one i don't know support the
center
yeah actually yeah i love sportscenter
i'm like
this on sportscenter what's my shoe size
oh so this well varies but you can
you'll go like seven six and a half
seven men
yeah yeah which put you like eight eight
and a half
probably eight women's eight women yeah
okay how do you know when i'm mad at you
so it doesn't happen very often no yeah
yeah there's like a look on your face
which is just like
actually like no expression it's just
very like because usually you're very
expressive
yeah it's very difficult to make you mad
all basically all the ways in which you
like express yourself
shut down they shut all down and then
i'm like oop
i did it that is a big tale because i am
wild who's my biggest soccer influence
oh so i know your favorite women's
players is lil christine lilly yep shout
out yeah christine lilly influence i
mean you
because i would say i feel like it might
be like rach it might be your sister
it's like your family
yeah probably my brother brian okay yeah
brian
rache lill okay elite company there in
that order yeah
what's my favorite city to play in
with what the international the sports
national team okay okay and wsl i think
is portland
yeah lit so good they have they have
amazing fans and it's like seattle and
they hate us
yeah but i think they kind of like me
your favorite city
maybe l.a because your family can go or
something like that
yeah that's a good my are you like i
feel like am i answering these for you
you're like okay that's a good idea
you're right but it's my favorite i love
that place
what is my most famous celebration
but what is also one of my favorites
okay
well the pose is your most famous
yep megan will like watch something on
twitter like a like a gif and she will
then
be like oh i should do this as my goal
scoring celebration
so there was one with the rain where you
did like that green
guy uh yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was like a yeah yeah well i feel
like
two did really well i don't know if i
should be surprised by that
i don't know we'll see you're taking
you're taking notes when i'm just
rambling around the house so
sue got this many right uh which i feel
like is a lot
so thanks babe all right i just finished
answering megan's questions
and now it's my turn you ready yeah
these are pretty easy okay i hope so
where did i grow up
sorry awesome
island what's my favorite color blue
yes yes how do i like my coffee
this is easy um you like your coffee
with a little bit of alternative milk
whether it's oat milk or almond milk
right now
we're in the almond milk no we're not
we're in the oatmeal i meant oat milk
that's what i meant half point
she literally makes our coffee every
morning so it's a little questionable
how that okay
what are three things i never leave the
house without a mask
you're really good at you never forget
your phone
and your car keys and usually me
usually you yeah i know you've got on
purpose i'm like where are you going
she's attached i'm coming
what's my favorite tv show well i know
you really liked the ending to six feet
under
okay um that's my favorite ending
sopranos
okay good job babe what was my favorite
basketball team growing up
the liberty bells oh the new york knicks
did i ever have a job that wasn't
playing basketball aka what was my first
job ever
selling um ice cream out of a little
push cart
at the racetracks and at concerts yes in
upstate new york
yes and she got robbed one time got
robbed on time yeah
yeah ruined me scarred me very not
hadn't had another job since
stayed away from those jobs what's my
favorite ice cream flavor
cookie dough no
oreo yeah cookies and cream cookies and
cream yeah
okay but like you get half a point
because ben and jerry's half baked
is actually like my ben and jerry's
favorite and that has cookie dough in it
perfect there you go oh what's the first
meal i ever cooked for you
it's either our standard go-to which is
it wasn't that okay
um piccata yeah yes
how do you know when i'm mad at you
homegirl says it yeah
normally because you're just like i'm
mad at you what number did i wear in
college
10. i could ask myself this i wouldn't
know it when is super day in seattle
no idea i'm sure the proclamation is
somewhere in the story yeah
what's the answer october 4
4 what are my favorite snacks to eat
while watching a movie
um how about this at a movie theater
that's like an easier
popcorn lots of salt it's more like salt
and then there's some popcorn
on top of the salt whatever it can go
with salt yeah oh man vehicles for salt
that's sue
what's my favorite movie of all time you
love catch me if you can yeah all time
uh
you've got mail she goes to sleep to
that yeah
that sounded really weird but it's true
it's a
i don't know what your favorite is it's
a toss-up it's like a few good men
the rock what am i most scared of
oh this is tough
i think you're scared of letting people
down
you went deep too yeah yeah because i
was gonna say sharks or seaweed
i hate seaweed yeah you're not a big
ocean swimmer no
it's all kinds of stuff happening that i
don't like what's the first thing i do
when i wake up in the morning
you read the news yeah because you read
this i wake up like
significantly earlier over now earlier
yeah yeah and megan doesn't like when i
get out of the bed
don't you dare what year did i win my
first wnba championship
2004 okay bonus list all the years i've
won
four eight
eighteen twenty
ding wait no i didn't win in o8 i'm
sorry that was the olympics
four ten ding 10 18
20. because you've never won in a odd
year
what other sports did i play in high
school soccer
and track yes yeah we always have a
fight about who's
who's faster it's not me right now
not you right now it's nothing neither
of us are faster than each other right
now
what's my full my short legs what's my
full
what's my full birth name suzanne
bridget bird
okay bonus what was going to be my full
birth name
oh my god i have no idea i've definitely
told you this
no courtney elizabeth i never told you
that
courtney yeah no thank god they went the
other way you're suit of the core
what city do i enjoy playing in the most
new york yes
what's my cell phone number
that is correct why do you know it i
know it because at press juice where we
get our little snacky poos
that's the account that it's under but i
feel like i would have known it
who is my biggest basketball influence
herschel bird
mr dirk
your biggest basketball influence your
coach
um liz oh jill jill it could be jill
yeah
it would be jeweler coach or emma those
are gen easy gen easy there we go yeah
all right a emma of course last one
what is my proudest career
moment 2018 championship
it's okay not to that not okay
that is correct is it yeah you worked
for that one
i worked for that one yeah you did all
right all out of questions
uh you guys can let us know how you
think megan did but this
was her score pretty good you want to
keep playing
i have more
[Music]